salió al balcón de su casa;
una madre soltera que había ganado con su hija a su lado.
(Aplausos)
Esta mujer es un gran modelo a seguir
para mí y para mucha gente de esa época,
incluso niños.
A menudo relata la historia de cómo un niño pequeño se acercó a ella
cuando ya llevaba un par de legislaturas
y le preguntó: "¿Los niños pueden ser presidentes?".
(Risas)
Tener modelos a seguir es importantísimo,
pero aún teniendo figuras tan fuertes,
por las que estoy muy agradecida,
cuando me animaron a postularme como presidenta,
mi primera reacción fue: "¿Quién soy yo para ser presentarme?
¿Quién soy yo para ser presidenta?".
Al parecer, menos mujeres
se plantean postularse en comparación con los hombres.
Según un estudio americano llevado a cabo en 2011,
el 62% de los hombres había considerado presentarse a las elecciones,
frente a un 45% de mujeres.
Eso es una diferencia de un 16%,
y es la misma diferencia que existía hace una década.
Y es una pena
porque estoy convencida de que el mundo necesita líderes femeninos
y, en general, un mayor liderazgo
basado en principios.
Así que la decisión de candidatarme
básicamente se explica
por el hecho de que sentía
que tenía que aportar mi granito de arena,
y, aunque no tenía experiencia política,
dar un paso adelante y contribuir a la creación de un mundo
coherente y sostenible
para nuestros hijos,
y un mundo en el que verdaderamente permitamos a nuestros niños y niñas
ser todo lo que pueden ser.
Fue la mejor etapa de mi vida.
Fue increíble.
La aventura comenzó con hasta 20 candidatos potenciales.
Se redujo a nueve candidatos clasificados
y finalmente quedamos cuatro,
tres hombres y yo.
(Aplausos)
Pero el drama no acaba aquí.
Si piensan que hay drama en EE. UU
puedo...
(Risas)
Puedo asegurarles que nosotros tuvimos lo nuestro en Islandia.
El que había sido nuestro presidente durante 20 años
en un principio anunció que no iba a presentarse,
lo que probablemente provocó
que tantos candidatos consideraran la presidencia.
Luego cambió de parecer
cuando nuestro primer ministro renunció,
después de que él y su familia
se vieran implicados en los infames Papeles de Panamá.
Hubo una protesta popular en Islandia,
así que el actual presidente pensó que necesitaban un líder de confianza.
Unos días después, su mujer y las compañías de su familia
fueron relacionados con los Papeles de Panamá,
así que se retiró de la carrera de nuevo.
Antes de hacerlo, dijo que se retiraba
porque había dos hombres cualificados
que él pensaba podían ocupar su lugar en la presidencia.
Así que el 9 de Mayo, 45 días antes de las elecciones,
el panorama no pintaba bien para mí.
No salía ni en los gráficos de la prensa.
Las encuestas me daban un 1%,
siendo el mejor resultado
que una candidata había conseguido jamás.
Me quedaría corta si dijera que tuve que trabajar muy duro
para ganarme un sitio en la mesa
y salir en televisión,
porque la cadena decidió que solo invitaría
a aquellos con un 2,5% o más en las encuestas
al primer debate televisivo.
La tarde del primer debate televisivo
me enteré de que participaría junto a los tres hombres,
y, ya en directo,
de que había obtenido exactamente un 2,5% en las encuestas ese mismo día.
(Aplausos)
Bueno, retos.
Los principales retos que tuve que afrontar y superar
fueron: medios, apoyo y dinero.
Empecemos con los medios.
Hay gente que dice que el género no importa
en materia de prensa y política.
No puedo decir que esté de acuerdo.
Yo lo tuve más difícil para acceder a los medios y tener minutos de pantalla.
De hecho, el principal candidato apareció en los medios
87 veces en los meses precedentes a las elecciones,
frente a mis 31.
No digo que los medios hagan esto de forma consciente.
Creo que nace fundamentalmente de una subjetividad inconsciente
porque en los medios, como en cualquier ámbito,
existe la subjetividad consciente e inconsciente,
y debemos tener coraje para denunciarlo si queremos cambiarlo.
Cuando, por fin, tuve un hueco en la tele,
la primera pregunta que me hicieron fue: "¿Vas a abandonar?".
Y era una pregunta dura.
Pero, claro, con entre un 1% y un 2,5% en las encuentas,
es incluso comprensible.
Pero los medios son muy importantes y cada vez que aparecía en la tele,
veíamos y experimentábamos una subida en las encuestas;
así que sé de primera mano sobre su importancia
y por qué necesitamos hablar del tema.
Fui la única de los cuatro candidatos
que no tuvo una entrevista en portada.
A veces, me dejaban fuera de las preguntas que se les hacían a los otros candidatos
y de la cobertura electoral.
Enfrenté esto,
pero diré algo a favor de la prensa islandesa.
Hubo pocos o ningún comentario sobre mi pelo y traje pantalón.
(Aplausos)
Bien hecho.
Pero hay otro factor importantísimo.
Me postulé como candidata independiente,
sin ningún partido político o apoyo detrás de mí.
La falta de experiencia
y de acceso a recursos
probablemente nos costó la campaña
pero también nos permitió innovar y hacer política de una forma diferente.
Dirigimos una campaña positiva
y, al hacerlo, seguramente cambiamos el tono de las elecciones para otros.
Puede que por eso tuviera menos minutos de pantalla,
porque quería mostrar respeto hacia otros candidatos.
Como los medios parecían tan inaccesibles
usamos nuestros propios medios.
Conduje sesiones de Facebook live
en las que respondía a los votantes sobre cualquier tema y en directo.
Y publicábamos todas las preguntas y respuestas en una página pública
porque pensamos que la transparencia es importante
si quieres generar confianza.
Y como llegar a los más jóvenes resultó ser un desafío,
me pasé a Snapchat.
Recurrí a gente joven para que me enseñaran
y usé todos los filtros de Snapchat durante la última parte de la campaña.
Y tuve que ponerle mucho humor y humildad porque se me daba fatal.
Pero crecimos en popularidad entre los jóvenes solo con hacer eso.
Así que es posible liderar una campaña diferente.
Pero, desafortunadamente, no se puede hablar de política sin nombrar el dinero.
Me entristece que sea así, pero es la verdad,
y nosotros teníamos menos recursos que el resto de candidatos.
Esto se debe, en parte,
a que creo que encontraba difícil solicitar apoyo económico.
A lo mejor, también tenía la ambición de hacer más con menos.
Algunos dirían que es muy femenino por mi parte.
Pero, a pesar de todo, con un tercio de los recursos mediáticos y económicos,
y un equipo emprendedor, pero maravilloso,
logramos sorprender a todos la noche electoral,
con los primeros resultados.
Hasta yo estaba sorprendida, como podéis ver en la foto.
(Risas)
Según los primeros resultados,
iba igualada con el candidato principal.
(Aplausos)
No canten victoria porque no gané
pero quedé segunda,
y habíamos progresado mucho desde el 1%,
con casi un tercio de los votos,
y superamos las encuestas con un margen sin precedentes,
o 10 puntos porcentuales por encima de las últimas previsiones.
Mucha gente dice a causa de esto que soy la verdadera ganadora
y otros tantos me animan a que me presente de nuevo.
Pero lo que de verdad me enorgullece
es saber que proporcionalmente
tuve mayor apoyo por parte de los jóvenes,
y muchos quieren que mi hija se presente en 2040.
(Aplausos)
Tiene 13 años
y nunca había salido en la tele antes.
Y el día de las elecciones la observé en televisión
y se mostraba inteligente y segura de sí misma,
y sincera y a favor de su madre.
Esto fue lo más destacado de mi campaña.
(Aplausos)
Pero hubo otro momento.
Estas son unas niñas de preescolar
que encontraron mi póster en la parada de bus
y sintieron la necesidad de besarlo.
Público: ¡Oh!
Esto fue un triunfo en sí mismo.
Si podemos verlo, podemos serlo.
Así que, a la porra el miedo y los desafíos.
(Aplausos)
Es importante que las mujeres se postulen
y es hora de que las mujeres se candidaten,
sea para dirigir una empresa o un país.
Me las ingenié también para llamar la atención de vuestro "New Yorker".
Me gané un nuevo título: "Un emoticono viviente de la sinceridad".
(Aplausos)
Es el título del que estoy más orgullosa
y es porque a las mujeres a menudo se las penaliza
por usar lo que yo llamo su capital emocional,
pero sé por experiencia que somos muy buenas
cuando hacemos precisamente eso.
(Aplausos)
Y necesitamos más de esto.
Lo celebramos como si hubiéramos ganado
porque así lo sentíamos.
Así que no se trata necesariamente de ganar
sino de ir a por ello,
y tú, tu familia y amigos, y todos lo que trabajan contigo,
si lo haces bien, crecerán más allá de lo que lo hayan hecho nunca.
Lo pasamos bien
y aprendí mucho en esta aventura,
quizás más de lo que podría compartir aquí
con el tiempo que tenemos.
Pero créanme, requiere un gran esfuerzo.
Fueron unos meses de falta de sueño.
Tuve que ser fuerte y perseverante para no abandonar,
pero aprendí algo que ya sabía desde antes del día del 1%,
y es que solo puedes ser bueno
cuando de verdad escuchas lo que dicta tu propia voz
y trabajas en sintonía con ella.
Como bien dice mi hermana algunas veces,
puedes traicionar a tu intuición,
pero tu intuición nunca te traiciona a ti.
También es muy importante, y Uds. ya lo saben,
que en cualquier aventura
todo depende del equipo que elijas.
De tener gente a tu alrededor que comparte tus valores y visión
pero difieren en todo lo demás.
Esa es la fórmula del éxito para mí,
y yo soy afortunada de tener un marido maravilloso,
que está aquí hoy,
y una familia increíble...
(Aplausos)
y amigos estupendos,
y juntos, como emprendedores en la esfera política,
conseguimos algo que todo el mundo creía imposible.
De hecho, el principal experto en RR. PP
me dijo, antes de tomar la decisión,
que tendría suerte si llegaba al 7%.
Agradecí su opinión, que seguramente era acertada
y se basaba en una preciada experiencia.
Pero el día del 1%
decidí demostrarle que se equivocaria.
Es importante recalcar esto porque no dormí mucho
y trabajé muy duro, pero también lo hizo mi gente.
Nunca podremos llegar lejos si no cuidamos de nosotros mismos.
Hay dos cosas que son muy importantes:
una es rodearse de gente y prácticas que te enriquecen,
la segunda, que es igual de importante, o incluso más,
es tener coraje para deshacerse de la gente y prácticas
que te desgastan,
y eso afecta a los maravillosos blogueros y comentaristas.
Recibí el apoyo de muchos
y tomé la decisión de crecer cuando otros se rebajaban,
y así es cómo, en buena parte, me mantuve con energía durante el proceso.
Y cuando la perdía por un momento;
y la perdí alguna que otra vez, no fue fácil...
volvía a la razón que me empujó a presentarme
y cómo había decidido dirigir mi propia campaña.
La llamé la campaña 4G,
en la que las ges representan palabras islandesas.
La primera es "Gagn".
Me presenté para hacer el bien,
para servir,
y quería que un liderazgo de servicio
estuviera en el centro de mi trabajo y de quien participara en la campaña.
La segunda es "Gleði," o felicidad.
Me comprometí a disfrutar de la aventura.
Había mucho que extraer de este viaje,
independientemente de si llegábamos al destino o no.
E hice todo lo posible para inspirar a otros a hacer lo mismo.
La tercera es "Gagnsæi".
Estaba abierta a cualquier pregunta.
No tenía secretos,
se publicaba todo en Facebook y en las páginas web.
Porque creo que si vas a elegir a tu presidente,
mereces tener respuestas a tus preguntas.
Por último, pero no menos importante,
no necesito explicarles
que basamos la campaña en el principio de "Girlpower".
(Aplausos)
Estoy verdaderamente contenta
de haber tenido la valentía de hacer esto,
de enfrentarme a la derrota pero sentirme
vencedora en tantos niveles.
No puedo decir que fuera fácil
pero puedo afirmar,
y creo que todo mi equipo coincidirá conmigo,
en que mereció la pena.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Pat Mitchell: No te puedo dejar ir.
Halla Tómasdóttir: Qué público tan bueno.
PM: No puedo dejarte ir sin señalar
que seguro que todo el público está dispuesto a irse a Islandia
y votar por ti.
Aunque seguro que no podríamos votar allí.
Una cosa que podemos extraer de Islandia
y hemos extraído siempre es inspiración.
Yo soy lo suficientemente vieja como para recordar 1975,
cuando las islandesas salieron a la calle,
y fue un factor clave para el movimiento por los derechos de la mujer.
Lo has mencionado antes. Me gustaría proyectar la foto de nuevo
y que nos haga recordar lo que suponía que un país se paralizara.
Y lo que a lo mejor no saben,
porque la prensa americana no lo ha cubierto,
es que las islandesas salieron de nuevo a la calle el lunes, ¿no?
HT: Sí, así es. PM: ¿Qué puedes contarnos sobre eso?
HT: Sí, 41 años después de la huelga,
podemos ser el mejor país para ser mujer,
pero el trabajo no está hecho.
Así que a las 2:38 p.m. del lunes,
las mujeres abandoraron su trabajo
porque es cuando habían ganado su sueldo diario.
(Aplausos)
Lo fantástico de esto
es que jóvenes, hombres y mujeres,
participaron en mayor número esta vez,
porque ya es hora de que pongamos fin a la diferencia salarial.
PM: No voy a pedirle a Halla que nos confiese ahora mismo
cuáles son sus planes,
pero diría que tienes una amplia legión de voluntarios
si decidieras presentarte de nuevo.
Gracias, Halla.
HT: Gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)